hi welcome everyone I'm absolutely
delighted to have you all here my name
is Priya Nataraja and I'm a theoretical
astrophysicist and I'm the new director
of the Frankie program in the science
and humanities at Yale and this is the
first event that we put together for
this academic year so thrilled to have
benefactors Barbara and Richard Frankie
here thank you so much for coming to
this event and and I went to start off
by saying what a delight it is to have
the opportunity to hear from Allison
shots today so Allison was a visiting
fellow an artist-in-residence at Yale
the Bob Dornan artist-in-residence in
2008 and so it was at that time that
both John but Lafleur who is in the
department of geology and geophysics and
I have the good fortune of running into
her actually she came out seeking us to
to become facts correctly and I was
amazed at her artistic sensibility and
the combination of curiosity in the very
scientific sense as we define it so her
work really represents in a way the
bridge between the so-called two
cultures
one of the most act ways to start the
first series of Franke programming for
for this year and her work has been
shown widely she's extremely well
regarded she lives and works out of
Brooklyn New York and I think what's
super exciting is that she is going to
be included in a new exhibition called
art and space at the Guggenheim Museum
in Bilbao and was recently included in
the exhibitions the more things change
at the San Francisco Museum of Modern
Art contemplating the void I'm reading
out the name
of many of the exhibitions to show you
how when you see her work and her
talking about her work you will see how
she really is quite informed by her deep
interest in the notions of space
geometry and abstraction so she's had
solo exhibitions
in you know all kinds of exciting venues
like the sculpture Center in Dallas
Texas the Indiana Indianapolis Museum of
Art the Wexner Center for Arts in
Columbus Ohio and the Espace Louie
Vuitton in Tokyo amongst other places
she is of course also been exhibited at
the Solomon R Guggenheim Museum in New
York light and landscape at the storm
King Art Center and her works have been
included now in many public collections
including at the Guggenheim in New York
the Hirshhorn Museum in DC the Whitney
Museum of American Art the San Francisco
Museum of Modern Art amongst amongst
other places so I'm thrilled to have
Allison here today and without much
further ado I would turn over to her and
look forward to learning a lot more
about the lens with which you see both
the world
[Applause]
Thank You Priya it's really great to be
back here at you thank you for inviting
me it's just it's very it's really kind
of almost weirdly nostalgic to be back
here and seeing these these the old yale
buildings which are so beautiful my work
kind of truly began in 1994 with a
question about space i'm wondering what
is space what is it made of how does it
shape everything that we see around us
that interest began really in art school
but sort of serviced in this work here
but also i would just also want to say
that you know then through priya and
through other we you know reading other
things and physics I learned that space
is very elusive and we still don't
totally know what it is I think so
that's kind of interesting because that
became my obsession I'm also interested
so I'm interested in visualizing space
and also interested in visualizing
gravity and thinking about light so
those three things are the main almost
like materials of my work so if you
think about normal materials of art
being like paint and paper I like to
think of my materials being gravity
space and light this work is called
reflective mimicry and this is really I
guess this must be 1994 I'm really bad
with the dates I will not be going
chronologically also in this talk but
this is early and I like to kind of
sometimes show this first because this
is the thing so I had been thinking
about just the boundary between myself
and space and I wanted to dissolve that
boundary and so I made this suit that
you know made of mirrors and this became
a project in photography and video I
won't be showing the video today though
because it's too long but through this I
was trying to kind of think about the
idea of solidity and what is solid and
what is space and you know why do we
even think of some things as solid of
course they feel solid to us but they
really have space in them which I find
hard to conceive so when I made this
piece I also realize it was sort of
dealing with space and an interesting
way visually so things that were solid
or appearing to be not solid in the
photograph at least and I also made this
kind of like further extension I thought
well the body is there but then it's not
really extending out enough so I made
this back piece and there were actually
hand pieces also that came off my
fingers and for some reason I didn't
include those in the photo but that's
sort of like extended the boundary
further and then I made some videos with
this with a dancer
this is skipping much ahead
somewhere around 2003 what just fell
this is called narrow fence this is a
permanent peace at Socrates oh no sorry
storm king sculpture Center so this is
up now although I'm not sure storm king
is open but it's up anytime you go and
this work it's a fence and it's 140 feet
long it's made of glass and here I was
trying to make the space and the solid
stuff sort of equalized and what ended
up happening was that
because those those intervals are kind
of equal your I doesn't know what's
solid in what space and so when you are
by it it just kind of seems to flicker
and it becomes almost in a way digital
like a digital effect and again the
boundary is sort of being dissolved
another thing that's important in my
work is that it changes I wanted to you
know I thought about change a lot and I
think when I was first working and I
never would create a rule for myself and
never would I say like no mechanical
things in my work but so far I don't
want to have mechanical change just
because I always think well that's going
to break and then I'll have to fix it
that'll be a pain so I wanted to
incorporate change but I wanted to be
natural change and this worked because
it's reflecting its surroundings and
just part of its surroundings obviously
it's changing with the seasons and with
the time of day or you know a cloud
passes and that changes that this is a
snow and actually I need to get a better
picture of it in snow because it really
kind of almost disappears and then you
could kinda see like the shadows
this is called brake line this is very
new and so for years I was thinking wow
I really like Mir fence and how can I
continue that but make it you know
change it in some way and I wanted to
make a kind of like a curvy fence but
it's interesting I mean just Donna I
don't know if this is a scientifically
related note or not but I think you can
have an idea and then that idea can just
take a really long time to come to
fruition and to find it's right Avenue
so I was trying to sort of like draw the
curve I was thinking of modeling it in
the computer and finally when I got the
opportunity to make this piece I brought
out it's based on one of the snow fences
that you see like on beaches or in snow
and we took an actual wooden snow fence
out on the property and just let it kind
of physically react to the topography
underneath and to its own materiality so
it's connected like wood pieces
connected by wires and so we we set it
up and it sort of flopped this way and
flopped that way and then we just
recorded it each picket and like where
it was falling and that's how the shape
was determined so it's really responding
to gravity and that's something that's
really important in my work I'm really
interested in gravity and just I just
find it really beautiful in a way like
the shapes that gravity create you know
these things are not something I created
and oftentimes I'm you know and even in
their using reflection in my work it's
because I don't want to create the color
I sort of want it to be created by
nature by somebody not somebody else but
just the physics of the environment
around us so I'm really interested
that's just showing the change at night
at night it's really
I really like it this is a video in
which the sound I guess doesn't work but
it's pretty short movement you can see
also that it becomes like visible and
invisible depending on what the song is
doing depending on your angle and
relationship to it some fancy drone
footage
okay this is the poster image this is
called scattering screen this is also
relatively new actually I was thinking
about I do a lot of large-scale
sculpture and outdoor sculpture and I'm
always thinking about outdoor sculpture
that I've seen in the past and how I
want to respond to that and I wanted to
make a large-scale metal sculpture that
wasn't like a typical large-scale metal
sculpture that's like a solid kind of
chunk that's painted so this is lots of
little circles and obviously relates
very much to that first image that we
saw reflective mimicry it's lots of
little steel circles that are kind of
almost sewn together just with wires so
it's it's wired together but it's quite
sturdy and it's not hanging from the
trees that's everybody thinks it is but
I think that that's not safe for the
tree but it's supported from the back
but with this sculpture
I was thinking almost about like showing
the air just making the air and the
sculpture equal so it's a sort of
similar idea in a way to reflective
mimicry but yet it's more of a space or
an environment to be in versus a body
this is the piece that was at the
Guggenheim New York it's called the
shape of face and that did sort of
define this lecture as well that name to
find the lecture but I was reading about
space and the possible eleven dimensions
of space and it was such an interesting
idea and it was really new at that time
and I have no idea what the status is
right now I'm looking at Maria it's
profound it's probably over by now but
in any case at that time that was the
current thinking is that there were 11
dimensions of space and I was like oh my
god what does that look like how can I
picture that and there were these things
called calabi-yau shapes which actually
became kind of influential to me and
thinking about folded space so this is
made out of lenses it's made out of
clear plastic lenses but they're the
kind of thing that you use like to read
the newspaper if you're having a hard
time using these paper they're very
flexible plastic lenses they're not
thick they're like two pieces of paper
thick and they're stapled together just
with well with stainless steel staples
and and they're hand cut so another
thing that's important in my work is
that though it's sort of massive there's
like a human human 'ti like a human
scale to it and I felt like you know
maybe I could have gotten those lenses
cut I'm not sure how laser cut wouldn't
work but let's say there was some way of
doing it but I really wanted them to be
hand cut so that there was like a
humanity to it and the other thing is
this piece also I don't know if I have
okay that's another I don't think I have
pictures of this through that through
time but it also changes dramatically as
the Sun changes another thing I probably
should say is that I've always been a
little bit interested in optics so I
guess that's another sort of scientific
connection I've always loved lenses and
looking through microscopes and looking
through telescopes and just something
away the way that you see differently
through those
this is really interesting to me and
then even I did a glass residency and
even learned how to make lenses at one
time well it was quite the long process
this is called geometry of light I
believe this is a Tokyo just get the
head and just possibly be Tong
these are lenses also but sort of
arranged differently this is kind of not
the whole show but you're seeing part of
the whole show
it's a light-filled space and so it
really worked beautifully with my work
and maybe it was the first time that I
got to see indoor work in a space or
light could really interact with it and
I was thinking of this as kind of light
you know as a particle and a wave and
how I would picture that oh I forgot to
say that in the shape of space I was
trying to picture these eleven donors
the dimensions of space and though I
knew that that sculpture was nothing
like eleven dimensions of space it was
kind of like my attempt to picture that
I don't really care that it's not a you
know scientific depiction it's my
imagining of it and in within that
sculpture there were these because their
lenses if you got into a curved images
were sort of projected outwards and so
there was this kind of strange
dimensionality that happened this one I
was thinking of light as a particle and
a wave and thinking of light almost
stopped in time and what it might look
like and so these are lenses sort of
struggle longer wire with beads in
between I guess I can look here it also
became something like a cloud and like
each lens kind of like a drop of water
and you know part of what I'm interested
in is is having my work be like a
atmospheric thing not always but
sometimes so something you can kind of
be inside like a weather event or
something and that's something that's
changing and apparently in Tokyo and I
guess they're different than here and
maybe they have a bigger attention span
longer attention span but apparently
people were setting up they had these
little cushions and people would set up
cushions and watch the sculpture for
hours and they've come back you know on
multiple days which was so wonderful
because that's what I really would like
people to do this is you can start to
see the light changing here and these
are again like hand-cut lenses and
beaded there's a lot of handwork
typically as you can see how it changes
somewhat through the oh I also have this
video that's a short time lapse
the other thing I mean now that I see
that and reminded also that it became a
kind of clock because the shadows were
obviously moving across that white floor
and you know every day the shadow would
change of course with a changing angle
of the Sun and the season and I went
back in I think I installed it in
September maybe or August and then I
went back in December it was a
completely different experience the
shadows were way longer and I started to
think of it almost like a sundial or
something or just a way to perceive the
movement of the earth around the Sun you
know or just to make people more aware
of that this is called invariant
interval I look questioningly at pre f4
that it was some might say it's very
difficult to title artworks but I'll
just talk about what the work is about
because I'm not sure that it's totally
appropriately titled but I was thinking
about this is about 25 feet high and I
don't remember the width but I do
remember the height it is made of glass
beads and wire so the whole thing is
sort of hand beaded and it the idea was
to make something a lot of my work kind
of starts system it becomes small and
expands up but this is like one where I
really intentionally wanted to deal with
that idea of like expansion of space so
when this sculpture is deinstall this is
flat and tiny really and then it expands
up into this shape and it really could
have even kept going honestly like if
the ceiling was higher we could have
gone higher so it's sort of showing
again like a way to show space I feel
like the inside of this is just space
showing itself you know it may be hard
to see that this is like I do have a
video for this and I think it kind of
flattens out but it's so dematerialized
and I'm really interested in show
vol without mass also so this is a
really good example of that there's kind
of see it there so basically as I bring
the sculpture up it's kind of starts to
shape itself and I try to let things
happen as you can tell from some of the
previous work
just let the the gravity and the
materiality of the thing work together
to create the shape so I try to guide it
a little bit but not too much because I
feel like I'm really interested in
seeing like what what does that do and
this is at the Brooklyn Museum in New
York and this one really reacts to light
because those beads are there like a
silvered glass and so as the Sun changes
actually at the Brooklyn Museum it
became almost electrified with the Sun
was surprising to me oh I found this was
in the New York Times so I'm sure people
saw this but this is a gravitational
wave animation that they've just
published with the new thing discovery
of gravitational waves of I go and I was
like oh my god that looks like my
sculpture
I mean it kind of blew me away because
the other thing about that sculpture I
think well here's one this is a sideways
orientation of a different one if you
touched as part of that sculpture the
whole sculpture reacts so it's really
acting like that animation and so it
does lead me to think I mean in my more
positive days you know I'm onto
something like I think that maybe by you
know just doing this kind of
experimentation like physical
experimentation if well you certainly
see things about the world I mean that's
for sure so they're not scientific but
they're observations of one kind or
another and for me they help me
understand more about the the physical
world just another view of it this is a
video that maybe shows a little more
three dimensionally I think I'm talking
in this
[Music]
[Music]
was I was thinking about a piece that
wouldn't stand from something very small
something very large
working with different methods yeah
maybe my Hoffman
I hit upon the correct method after a
long period of experimentation I was
very interested in creating you know
large volume without a lot of mass
that's something that's a very constant
in my work
[Music]
in terms of the light I'm interested in
navigating we present and not completely
present at the same time having a shift
in time so depending on your ankle or
your relationship to this work it
becomes invisible in some places and
some things that's very apparent and
with the natural light and Llewellyn
Museum with this window is great with
over here in the morning it looks
completely different than it does later
in the afternoon the natural light on it
changes it dramatically and I love the
natural light on it so depending on what
time of day do you see this sculpture
you may see it differently
[Music]
so that was from my show at the wellin
Museum at Hamilton College and I was
reminded by myself of that idea also
that I forgot about that that that
sculpture does really sort of disappear
at times or part of it will disappear a
part of it be apparent so it's kind of
like it looks like partial sculpture and
how is the rest of it what's happening
over there and that's kind of an
interesting thing this is the piece
that's owned by SFMOMA it's called the
structure of light this is earlier piece
and I remember at this time I was
thinking of defining space just almost
through lines or through drawing so also
using the beads but thinking of almost
like these kind of like layers of space
that you could walk through
these if you can see this picture really
but I also make these thread drawings
there thread and because he's better
maybe here there thread or yarn on pins
on the wall so there that one was maybe
like 50 feet long I don't remember
actually but let's see so I start with
making a shape in the computer it's kind
of I mean this is another thing that I
feel you know deals with dimensionality
to me so I'm working with a virtual
shape in the computer and then this is
the one at the well in there very hard
so these are the white on white ones
though they are a little bit hard to see
but I have some better pictures coming
out I take a virtual shape and I animate
it so I create a little world for it and
I create a little gravity space for it
and you know maybe wind or maybe no wind
or whatever and then I let the shape
fall down on most many times it's just a
plane I'm usually dealing with like a
flat plane and having it fall through
space but sometimes it could be a tube
or something just very basic and then I
stop it in the computer and photograph
it which I also find to be kind of funny
because it's like it's not really a
photograph but it's this virtual
photograph and from many different
angles and then I take that and that
becomes a template by which I make these
drawings and so these drawings are on
the wall but they're not flat on the
wall there are about two inches off the
wall and they look dimensional but
they're flat but they're not flat and
you know they also have shadows the lie
the yarn makes a shadow behind it which
is like a drawing line which actually
was the original intention of the whole
thing to begin with was that I didn't
really want to draw and I was trying to
find a way around drawing so I thought
well let the shadow do the drawing for
me
so anyway so they have this weird kind
of like they're not this and they're not
that I mean they're they could even
almost be called sculpture in the sense
but they're kind of drawing so I like
that in between this of them let's see
yeah sort of existing between two and
three dimensions that's more of a
close-up this is an example of a show I
had at Derek eller gallery and these
weren't called time lapse and I had done
a research fellowship at Stanford and I
ended up doing a lot of looking at
Eadweard Muybridge and I just fell in
love again with those photos I mean we
all do and but I saw more there because
he was there and I guess Leland Stanford
paid for him to do that stuff so there
was a huge collection there and I was
thinking about this idea of time lapse
and and I think about that anyway just
in terms of progression or change and
Muybridge was dealing with time through
photography or allowed us to see time
differently through photography and I
was thinking well you know I don't know
that I thought about this exactly this
way at the time but now I think of it as
you know this is like almost like a
virtual like we're living in this
virtual time and so this is this virtual
animation and virtual space and it's not
really real and this is like seeing time
through that technology I'd like to
think of it that way and so this is the
Saint you can see it's the same shape
sort of progressing through space and
time and then so it's the idea of like
this virtual space but then it's being
translated into this very human like
threading process which is very slow
just each one I'm I can't tell if that's
clear
these are some black ones that I
personally really like alright again I
can't tell if that's clear and the black
ones I really think of as space and I'm
actually doing some sculptures now that
I just realized kind of related to this
because they're black and I think of
them as almost like black holes
necessarily but like black space sucking
up the space around it so maybe it was
like a black hole in a way but it's not
supposed to represent that this was a
very like old piece and related to like
my research into space at that time
because I was I can't think I probably
kept asking for you what is the shape of
space what is the actual shape of our
universe and I guess there were at that
time you know was maybe a sphere maybe a
flat plane or maybe a hyperbolic plane
and this was I found this way of folding
a hyperbolic plane out of paper and I
said oh I'm just gonna like represent
all of space that way and I'm gonna I
did a lot of this was it must have been
when I was here because I remember
talking to the astronomy people are
getting map star maps and I was just
gonna do like all of the sky like this
and I didn't realize what a crazy notion
that was because it's very
time-consuming folding all that paper so
then I I did I think I started to do
that I changed my mind and eventually I
was looking at my rug and I thought well
though be interesting to show something
really that we can understand like a rug
and change it into a hyperbolic plane so
it's not exactly I wrote but if they're
all made of hyperbolic planes and that's
so that's my living room rug just
photographed you know piece by piece and
then folded up into this hyperbolic
shape
these are more sort of hyperbolic
they're hyperbolic paraboloids and I'm
not gonna go too far into it those as a
shape that I Erik Demaine at MIT made
popular I don't know if he invented that
shape or not but those are landscapes
folded this is a print group that I made
and so I should also say that my
interest in space as I sort of said
before it led to an interest in folding
and like a continued interest in folding
and folding just seems like such a
simple thing but yet it's like seems so
there's something very resonant about it
and it has contains all this sort of
potential energy and maybe that's why I
like it you know I don't know but I
can't seem to just stop dealing with
folding and I guess those khalaby Yahoo
shapes which are like folded spaces you
know may be led to that and then I
started reading about topology also
anyway this is a thing I did with Crown
Point press in San Francisco and this is
just a progression of folded paper shape
so it's the same piece of paper just
progressively folded more and more and
we inked the paper and we put it down
and run the prints and put a new color
on or run the print and so you see like
each color I'm just wondering if I can
walk here you know this pink which was
on the front side here when we inked it
then becomes here when I fold it some
more and so it just progresses forward
like that
and this is another here we did just
with more transparency instead of color
then I began to think you know I really
know the folding is very intentional and
you know I don't like as you may know by
now after this talk I don't like to
intentionally do anything in fact the
woman who was runs that print shop who's
a really famous woman and the print were
all up to Catherine Brown she wanted me
to use color and I was like oh no how
are we gonna choose the color cuz I
really can't figure out why you choose a
color in any case so then I thought okay
this folding is a little too intentional
and I'm not sure why I'm folding it this
way or that way
so I came up with the idea I mean it's
sort of an obvious progression to do
crumpling which is the type of folding
which is more chaotic and random and I
really like that and actually there's a
million ways you can crumple as well as
you you can kind of see here so these
are it's hard to tell in these photos
probably but they're made by taking a
piece of paper that large crumpling it
photographing it like precisely in a
grid putting that photograph back
together printing out a white piece of
paper so now you've got a printed image
of the crumples and then I reek Rumple
it again so it's got like printed and
real so it's got this sort of optical
thing going on where you know some you
think are physical but they're not some
are printed so it's double doubling
and I guess the big day of illusion is
you know was resonant to me I you know I
I don't like to get too far down that
road but this was just a little group of
folded paper pieces I made for a place
called geodon a they asked me again to
do a drawing and I freaked out oh no I
don't draw I mean I kind of draw but
yeah I really don't draw very much you
know and in the way that I make my
sculptures I just it's a trial and error
process and somebody once compared it to
like empirical research was just like
trying this try not not even once in a
while to make a drawing but not really
anyway so then I figured out oh I can
make these folded things and I can get
out of the whole drawing thing and then
that led to these and these are folded
aluminum so I really like those and I
thought well paper sculpture is very
difficult I had learned that through the
living room rug project and what can I
make these out of that would be more
long-lasting and I found you know just
aluminum that's somewhat foldable and
they're black because of the same idea
of just like folded space really and
it's funny because the well these aren't
that old actually but there may be a
couple of years old but now this is what
I'm doing right now but in a different
way but yeah I found them you know
really
I like to think that that's like what
space looks like these kind of folds of
blackness this is something I started
working in clay I don't know maybe six
seven years ago and I was trying this
time to do folding and clay and this is
what resulted so they weren't really
folded there had flopped and you know it
was okay
I was like well there's something nice
there and I like the the folds and then
I tried to figure out like how can I do
that more in a way that is something
that you know works with my work and so
these are you know and I don't even know
what happened and this is one of those
like great moments and work were you
just like something you just say well
I'm just gonna do this thing because I'm
you know desperate so I I had my slab of
clay and I rolled it around to a
cardboard tube and just dropped it
either on the ground or on the table it
was a small one like probably this big
and I this is so amazing you know like
the the wrinkles that are caused by that
dropping by the force and then it became
a huge like two year or something
Odyssey to get these I mean it really
was not easy because it's a porcelain
and porcelain is very delicate and it's
just I didn't realize so you can do that
and it looks really fantastic but then
immediately it wants to crack it wants
to like change and then as it dries it
wants to crack and that's like ah so I
have to babysit these you know every day
like tending to them so that they kept
there for her and actually it was just a
really long process to figure out how to
make to preserve that moment and so
really these are you know I was going to
talk about I titled these recumbent
folds but the there's a well let me keep
going
they're based in a certain way on
Newton's laws of motion like number two
in a way and kind of maybe number three
but force equals mass times acceleration
but then also that other one about the
body exerting the same force with the
other body or whatever what is it when
one body exerts a force on second party
the second body exerts a force equal in
magnitude and opposite direction to the
first body so these are made again by
now these became much bigger so then the
the porcelain was like this my slab was
huge and B was this high when I rolled
it and I had to have an assistant than
really heavy and we would drop that down
and so the force plus the materiality of
the clay plus the humidity of the room
and the day and all these things like
interact to create like this moment and
that's what I found really fascinating
that I really couldn't control it
there were like little things like a
kind of control like the the force at
which I dropped them the height but
really this is kind of like nature or
you know physics doing its thing through
art I guess this is an example of some
threat drawings I made based on that and
actually these are so this is like the
virtual version of that so then I made a
tube and had it like drop in virtual
space and made some thread drawings
based on that
and these are called laws of motion
really the other ones could have been
called that too oh and I think I just
didn't come up with that title and time
title it can be really nightmare oh yeah
so they're different so these are the
same idea but in bronze and these are
also unique so they're not edition dand
like a lot of bronzes are auditioned but
these are not so there are one-time
burnouts and the interesting thing I
think about these is that if you think
about the history of bronze sculpture
it's usually of course right now we're
all very aware of this but you used to
make monuments and I kind of think of
these as like monuments to like this
moment in time or this like one you know
interaction that happens and then it's
preserved I don't know about forever but
for a long time probably in bronze so
it's like a little monument this is a
recent sculpture called object for
reflection I just had a show of this at
Derek eller gallery and this is another
piece in which I'm just trying to think
about large-scale metal sculpture in a
new way so kind of related to that very
it's not early but we should I showed it
early in the in the slideshow so this is
lots of little aluminum pieces connected
with steel rings and so instead of metal
being this kind of rigid material it
becomes like a almost like a fabric or
like a material that reacts to gravity
which is important to me and also these
are they're really planes again there's
their flat planes when they begin but
then when they get supported and start
interacting with the space and the
gravity then they form their own shapes
and become not flat and it interacts
with light I mean I've you know since
that Louis Vuitton show I really like to
have
natural light and this we really didn't
have any fake light so it was just
changing all the time and I think in
this slide you can see that it's
transparent really so depending on the
light it's transparent or solid so kind
of shifting its physicality let's see if
there's anything else to say about that
yeah and really thinking about it I'm
really interested in redefining
large-scale sculpture metal sculpture or
just sculpture in general thinking about
it in different ways
oh here you can see how it's made kind
of so this I don't know if you say sadly
or crazily or whatever but this was all
just put together right hand so all
those little circles are folded but I
have a bunch of assistants and that's
how that happened
these are
these are called transitional objects
and they I talked earlier about the idea
of color and not wanted to choose the
color so I started using a while ago
many years ago I started using this
dichroic film which is clear but has the
kind of nano structure on it that
reflects the light one way or another
way to begin your angle
you know angle of the Sun or whatever so
it's like vaporized metals either onto
glass or onto a film or whatever it is
so it's like a real structure and it's
like the structure of a butterfly's wing
in a way and has that same kind of like
that's how the color of a butterfly's
wing is created versus like a pigment
and so what I like about it is that you
know as the light changes it changes and
this was shown at storm King also and we
just had natural light in there and and
the sculpture just changed constantly
and then I don't have to choose the
color I like that and this is a piece at
Stanford University it's a permanent
sculpture commissioned at the Li
cautioning center for learning and
knowledge and so this is made with that
same material and actually showed them
those smaller sculptures oh and you can
see here like this front sculpture if
you look at that green one you know that
yellow one is the same piece it's just
like a different time of day or whatever
it is but when they asked me to do the
Commission I showed them these smaller
ones that I just showed you and I really
want to make that big and they got
enthusiastic about it and went for it
so that was really fantastic oh and this
is called threefold and it's so it has
the center of topology reference in a
way that it's like this same shape to a
certain folder three different ways and
through this you can kind of see the
skin
just by seeing a person next to it oh
yeah so during the process of this I met
a professor there they do a lot of stuff
with proteins in that department and she
was talking about proteins and how they
act and how they're non-dimensional and
when they become folded they become
dimensional and active and they do their
work as a protein but until they're
folded they don't do that and that's
like totally interesting and I thought
it was there was also an analogy to my
sculpture because when I make these
sculptures in the computer I start with
a line that's actually non-dimensional
and I have to give it a dimension and
then you know as I give it a dimension
and start filling things out then it
becomes a sculpture and then it becomes
like a functional sculpture so there was
sort of an interesting analogy that is
aluminum sorry a lot of times I forget
to mention that stuff it's aluminum
structure with a dichroic film on plexi
so it's kind of a sandwich so there's
like aluminum welded structure and then
there's like plexi on both sides with
this film on it I have a video of this
to know if it says sound it does
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because he is a little long but
[Music]
sorry about that I think it's you know I
made that like a few years ago and I
really think our idea about like how
long a video she has changed I've gotta
edit it down a little bit but um that's
that's it thank you and I think we got a
glimpse of your inventiveness and your
originality you know much of my own work
I have to say it seems much more banal
working with the equations your work is
extraordinary else and it blew me away I
I'm interested in from afar and with the
change of light is one iteration but
when you get up close it's a totally
different sensibility yeah and equal is
beautiful I've been wondering if you
ever considered maybe one of those
pieces might have been going inside like
the ability for a person to go inside go
inside yeah I had that feeling I'd you
know if you want to identify with it
from a distance and then up close you
kind of want to get into it - yeah I
mean the shape space that piece that was
at the Guggenheim you could get really
close to it and you could be inside
those curves there are certain pieces
that you know like the invariant
interval pieces of expansion piece it
was very cool to be inside but some of
the problems with that are just a you
know like a crowd issue
typically you know then you get people
you'd be surprised what people do you
think this will be okay and then before
you know people are like climbing
something or you know you know who knows
what but I agree with you and and
actually I thank you for saying that
because I think that it's really
intentional on my part to make things
interesting close up and far away or
just at various distances so that they
seem almost different so sometimes some
of them you know you really you think
it's one thing for him far away and
close up it becomes something completely
a different object do you think has your
work evolved to think differently about
the human form and these other kinds of
gravitation or mathematical forms or do
you see them as entirely continuous and
how do you think about consciousness in
relation to that question I mean I'm not
sure how to define consciousness I'm I'm
not I think of the human form I don't
tend to pick the human form very often
so usually the human form like this is
only time and the work that I'm doing
right now is the shuttle of a human form
in a sense because I'm taking something
and manipulating it a lot so it's what
I've done to it and so maybe and there
there's like an echo and in terms of you
know consciousness and space and where
our place in the universe you know I
don't know
but I well I'll say one thing I don't
even know if this relates but I started
to a friend last night actually the
curator who invited me to do the artists
in residency here yeah and I was saying
that I oftentimes don't leave my studio
very often and I can get like very
wrapped up in there and because I feel
like I can go anywhere there like I can
travel the universe there and I don't
need to like go over it drag my body
somewhere else although I do often do
that but you know I feel like through
your mind you can travel wherever you
want and well maybe that's an answer
that's such a big question I was
wondering about the pieces that are
outside over time and you also talked
about the light how it changes over the
course of a day so the pieces outside
will eventually become maybe full of
algae and green stuff and so is that
something that you would encourage or uh
you know they won't do that only because
they have such care given to them so
it's storm king you know they preserve
all their sculptures and and
interestingly to me which I never knew
you know there's some giant Calder
sculptures there that are black and some
red ones painted metal they're very
beautiful but I thought oh those are so
easy to take care of no apparently those
need to be repainted like every couple
of years
fully repainted so anything outdoors
needs to be maintained and you know
probably they would get algae and all
that stuff if they were just sitting
somewhere non not being taken care of
but you know the one at snore King the
one in the the curvy one is in a private
collection and he's really meticulous
about keeping it in good shape which is
wonderful then
have some other works here and there
yeah they're also made of things that
don't you know necessarily deteriorate
that much so the glass is actually
holding up really well and the stainless
steel holds up pretty well with care a
natural way to connect dimensions is
through optical caustics have you know
what that is yeah so when when the
surface of a pool is rippling but on the
bottom of the pool you see sharp intense
light that light bounces around because
of the way in which the surface reflects
the light so connects the topography of
the surface to the plane yeah and it
evolves so it's it's something and that
is akin to the piece that you had in
Japan but it also is like the wrinkles
that you also see called optical
costings
anybody else yes so much of your work is
based on the perspective of the observer
and it makes sense because we're living
in a post Einstein yin age of relativity
but there's as the original initial
question showed when there's at once
it's there's emptiness for the same
volume sort of without mass there is
there is something fixed point in space
but also that changes over time so so
given that that it changes so much from
the perspective of the observer I was
wondering how the art has had different
receptions among different observers you
mentioned there was a bit of it the
different reception in tokyo i curious
how across different cultures or
different different spaces geography
it's been this sort of people have
interacted with your work differently
there is a cultural difference strangely
I've been showing a lot in Sweden and
you know I love your work in Sweden
because they love light and they really
you know think about light all the time
it's dark half the year and and I don't
know if they loves my work in Sweden or
not but I do feel like there's like a
understanding of it there you know there
is definitely like everybody does seem
to appreciate light and what it does so
I have noticed that you know it's here
there's a lot of selfie taking
some babies very narcissistic Cesare not
maybe we know it's another society yeah
everybody reacts differently and you
know one of my concerns going forward is
that people will become so absorbed in
their phones and have such short
attention spans that nobody's gonna take
the time to really experience something
overtime and I really want my sculptures
to be like that for instance that piece
the curvy fence piece I installed it it
was a boiling hot day and I think I got
like blisters it was so hot it was just
miserable and then he had also put down
this fertilizer that had like fish smell
and all these little bugs are coming out
and biting me and I was like wow this is
miserable so I just got out of there as
soon as possible I want to her done and
then I didn't go back for a long time
and then I had to get photographs of it
so he this couple family really invited
me to stay overnight because we want to
take pictures at sunset and sunrise and
so I got to see this work that I made
from afternoon into nighttime work
waking up at 5 a.m. seeing it with at
sunrise and I was like oh my god this is
really amazing and amazing in a way that
I wouldn't have experienced had I not
spent that time with it so anyway just
culturally I think I hope that people
want what is that idea I really I do
worry about
I think it's nothing to do
thanks so much for that so I was really
interested in this through line through
much of your work where it's almost like
you preserve the gravitational effects
at a single point in time and and even
sometimes like with the with the piece
outside next to the tree it's the
illusion of the gravitational effects
almost because you're supporting it
whereas you totally delight in the way
that the natural light changes and
animates the piece so I was I was
curious to what extent you've thought
about your your pieces showing the
effect of gravity over it over it over a
duration I haven't thought of it that
much they do do that anyway but in a
very subtle way or slow way so some of
the pieces are attached to whatever
ceiling or walls or whatever or through
[Music]
monofilament so they definitely sag
depending on what I use so they do sag
over time but it's an interesting idea
and I mean it would be an interesting
challenge to show somehow in a way that
would be interesting to show that you
know but the gravity is constant like
the force is sort of constant so it's
not changing so that's an interesting
idea
well threefold isn't really that was at
this point I guess it's not so probably
one of most complicated sculptures I've
ever made
so that's started by taking a shape in
the computer just a tube essentially
stretching it kind of twisting it three
different ways to create those shapes
that tubular shape and the computer I
mean really the line the thread drawings
and those sculptures are made the same
way in a weird way so they start the
same and they have two different
outcomes so I have this kind of linear
shape in the computer and I when I
started making these I was like I love
this linear shape I want this to be the
sculpture so then it was expanding out
those lines as I was talking about and
making them dimensional and then you got
you know these sort of planar forms and
then you've got to make all these uh
build drawings to build that so then
it's like dividing it up into the metal
parts and the plexi parts and numbering
lettering each and every part and then
we get the metal laser-cut usually
laser-cut sometimes water jet and the
plexi laser count
million zillion pieces it's like a giant
really it's like a giant
three-dimensional mosaic and that one we
had everything like lettered and
numbered and whatever and then
it gets welded up in parts so actually
so there were the three big shapes and
each shape is made up of like six shapes
that get put together because this heavy
has to fit through doors there's only
practical stuff so that lets get bolted
together and then once you've got one
shape you know then you you ring it and
lift it up and go to the next one but
the funny thing about that is sorry was
that I think it was like really quick
you know they took so long to happen so
long for me to decide to raise the money
and then once it happened there okay
want it like now and so it was like
maybe six months but that's actually not
that long and I had never done it before
so when we got to Stanford
they were its million loose pieces and
we just had these piles of like loose
pieces that Lexie like number like and
we were just feel like there's not even
have an a to you to be like finding a to
but it was really insane so how did that
that's crazy but that's how those get
made um the bronzes are me just like the
clay pieces um so you know two more I
make a slab and I have to make this lab
really nice and perfect and the word for
that is all of a sudden I can't remember
it but you know you get it so the fibers
are all like you smooth it down a lot so
the fibers are all connecting and then I
drop it and then that it's a different
type of clay for the bronze so that is a
waxy clay that they can then burn out
and I don't actually do this stuff I
don't really know how did you
bronze fabrication so I have it
fabricated somewhere else but they make
the the mold they burn out the the wax
clay and then they pour bronze into
there and
polish it well yeah that's like a few
I'm sure there's a few steps in there
and I think they make those in parts too
actually
I thought they made them all in my part
but then I saw some picture and I was
like oh my god you guys weld these and
then polish that yeah it's quite the job
I think that right it's exactly that
yeah yeah the bronze hasn't changed
really yeah I would love to see this in
person do you have any anything in the
Northeast that we can drive to go and
see I have the v6 storm king yeah it's
in mountain villa New York pushes about
an hour and a half out of the city I'm
not sure
from here it's probably pretty close I
don't know an hour maybe and I believe
they're still open they closed for the
winter but I don't know why I bet
they're still open
so yeah that's there
there was that picture yeah yeah this is
my own picture so honestly yes if I may
have a question about your creative
process so it's really beautiful the way
in which you are trying to catch
space-time light all these things that
are sort of constantly moving in a way
are sort of yeah carry motion right and
so how do you decide in your creative
process when you're done with the piece
because it seems like you know you could
keep going and shaping it further and
further so what is the process do you
start out with an initial conception of
what you really want and you go there
it doesn't quite sound like it it sounds
like you organically let the material
lead you there right yeah but when when
do you know you're done it's like an
elusive question really because um
actually I was just at a talk last night
an artist completely different than me
Peter saw somebody asked him the same
question what is he gonna say and he
just like you know you kind of sometimes
you just say like yes this is it
sometimes you feel like well maybe I
could go farther and then I guess
sometimes if I feel I can go farther
then maybe I make another piece if I
feel this one's kind of resolving itself
maybe it means I just need to explore
more in that you know same material or
whatever it is so like for instance like
object for reflection I had made that
was the piece that was the metal Sagi
piece
yes but then I made the one in New York
it's different actually they're
different and so there I felt like well
yeah it was good but I felt like I could
go further and yeah so it's sometimes
it's very obvious when I'm done and
sometimes but anyway I don't have a well
in this case I had to have it you know
something like this words like you will
you've got to build it and get
everything caught and whatever you've
got to have a preconceived notion but in
some of those other many of those other
pieces I just keep working on it now for
instance like the piece that Louie
Vuitton and Tokyo I couldn't fit that in
my studio that happens often and even
that big and very gentle integral piece
there was no way I can fit that in my
studio so I made part of it pray to God
that it works you know in the face and
you know think of it in my mind and make
all the parts and and then install it
and and with invariant interval which is
at ut-austin
it actually was challenging was really
challenging it was challenging in a way
well you know it'll be the material so
like suddenly you realize oh this is
light when it's you know this amount of
material but once this other amount of
material it's quite heavy and starts to
do this other thing and like just wants
to stick to the ground so that was you
know interesting but then you sort of
learn to deal with that on a larger
scale than anyway I'm sorry I'm not
really answering that question
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]